That organization, NASA, the the Hebrew
word for to deceive, to beguile, to
delude, to lead astray, is at their old
tricks again. Every time these guys try
to do something, they always get caught
slipping, whether it's, you know,
grabbing something that's not really
there because they're using augmented
reality or glitching away when they're
going into another room or playing with
some toy. Every time they get busted,
and that's just how it is, but people
who just they they have to believe this
stuff, no matter how many times they get
exposed, no matter how many times you
show wires and green screen glitches,
people are still going to believe this.
And if you want to see more proof,
please go to our channel, click the
video tab, and there's a 26-minute video
all about comparing ISS footage with ISS
footage, NASA footage with NASA footage,
and there's zero consistency. Please
watch that video, but this is hot off
the press, just in. Here is the latest
green screen glitch on Artemis. Check
this out. Watch this little ball.
They've been playing with this little
globe head ball, literally. And you see
these letters? You see I N?
You can see through this little ball as
it spins, and certain colors begin to
show,
and you can see that the green screen,
or the blue screen in this case, is
showing through, and you're actually
seeing letters
where it should be blue.
All right.
You got some 'splaining to do. I got
questions. If this is fake, then, you
know, point it out to me. Show me where
the original clip is, how this was
edited. There's a second one here, and
you'll see this piece of fabric here.
You're actually seeing what looks like
outside of the craft. I don't know if
that's stars that are moving by, but
here in a second you're going to see the
actual craft on this piece of blue
fabric that's floating behind this
person in here. Just keep watching this
scene,
and as it moves, you'll be able to see
what it's supposed to be.
And there's the the craft outside. This
is green screen fakery.
Why would there need to be any special
effects if this is just live footage of
people literally on a rocket right now
traveling through space to the moon?
How's it even traveling? There's no
atmosphere to push off of. You can't use
flame thrusters. Do they have just huge
CO2 tanks that are pushing air out? How
is this thing even navigating right now?
NASA should really just learn the tricks
from this guy. I mean, this guy can do
this on a TikTok selfie mode camera,
and he's better than NASA.
I mean, this guy has the tricks. A
friend of mine actually recorded this,
screen recorded it, sent it to me. Now,
I want you to pay attention to his
drawstring on his hoodie. What is
happening there? Why is this thing
bouncing?
Why is this Why is this drawstring
bouncing like it's on a roller coaster
ride or like an excited dog's tail?
There's no reason for that to be
bouncing the way it is. Nothing is
causing it to move. Nothing should be
moving unless it gets affected in some
way. See how it's resting on his chest,
and suddenly
it's like animatronics from a Jim Henson
puppet or something. It's just waving to
us. Hi, Mr. Drawstring.
And it reminded me of this video
from This is from a long time ago. This
is on the ISS.
And if you'll notice this pencil right
here floating,
um suddenly there's an acceleration.
What happened? You can see even stuff in
the background.
Everything in this cabin moves suddenly,
and it's a shift right there. What is
happening? The ISS is supposed to just
be coasting out here in outer space, but
in this scene,
it was caught that there was a a thrust
of some sort, and suddenly everything
that was floating just shifted and
moved. This should not be happening, but
these are the types of things that get
caught on camera, and people just ignore
it. They want to live in ignorance and
just keep believing in these lies that
literally come out from
the organization whose name in Hebrew
means to lie, deceive, beguile. Uh if
you guys are seeing stuff like this,
please let me know in the comments. I
want to share as much as this is
possible to use our platform to get the
truth out there, because Satan is out
here deceiving the entire world. There
is a reason that they are faking all
this space stuff, and today is
Easter Sunday, and we are told by Chris
Bledsoe's spirit guide, Hathor, that
something big is supposed to happen
today. I don't know if it's going to or
not, but we know that alien disclosure
is about to come. Government people are
saying that aliens are being bred with
humans in a secret military program.
Like, crazy things are happening right
now, but it's all a deception.
Don't buy into this stuff. If you like
this video, please give it a thumbs up.
Please share this with your family and
friends so they are not deceived by
these liars. If you would like to
support this ministry, you can do so by
going to candidtruth.org. We got Cash
App, Venmo, Zelle, PayPal. We cannot do
this without you. We have some cool
merch on our website. If you guys would
like to check that out, it really helps
this channel to continue to stay alive
because we are completely 100%
donation-based. If you would like us to
speak at your church or event or youth
group or school, we do that all the
time. Our calendar is getting filled,
but you can book us on our website. We
would love to come talk to you, come
meet you. If you've been donating to
this ministry, we want to say thank you.
We cannot do this without you, and we
will see you next time on Candid Truth.